تعثر ملحوظ للعديد من الانشطه التجاريه
الناشئه في السعوديه اسباب مختلفه وراء
هذا التعثر من بينها الحماس وعدم فهم حاجه
السوق وصعوبات التعامل مع الجهات الحكوميه
الاشرفيه فضلا عن الرسوم الماليه التي
تدفع البعض لتعليق انشطتهم او اغلاقها
بشكل نهائي
هنالك رسوم من من وزاره الشؤون البلديه
والقرويه هنالك رسوم التامينات الاجتماعيه
من وزاره
القوه البشريه او الموارد البشريه هنالك
رسوم زكاه وهنالك الرسوم غرف التجاريه الى
اخرها هنالك رسوم كثيره ترهق همم
المستثمره الصغير هو همم بغض النظر انه هل
هنالك يعني معونات للمؤسسات الصغيره
والمتصل لكن هذه الرسوم مرهقه جدا
وتحبط اا او تحبط من همه المستثمر تركي
مسفر شاب يوشك على انهاء مشروعه الذي كلفه
ربع مليون ريال بسبب عدم قدرته على مزاوله
نشاطه التجاري على الرغم من مشروعه النوعي
فهو يتخصص في تاجيل الدراجات الهوائيه
المتنقله في الحدائق والمسارات الرياضيه
جميع رخص المدفوعه السعر جميع اللائحه
التي طرحتها وزاره البلديه والشؤون
القرويه والاسكان متبعها بالكامل بند فلما
نتبع لائحه ونتبع جميع البنود ونطبقها
ونفندها في رخصه
همم صادم امامات منطقه الرياض ويمنع لي من
العمل تمام ما ادري ايش الطريقه او ايش
الحل الذي ممكن مع العلم اني وصلت الى
معالي الوزير تقصدك سابقا وصلت اليه مرتين
عده تساؤلات تطرح حول مستقبل الاعمال في
السعوديه
فبالرغم من الدعم الحكومي لتمويل المشاريع
الصغيره الا ان فشل البعض منها اصبح ملفتا
في الاونه الاخيره
من الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا الاكاديميه
المهتم برواداه الاعمال الدكتور فواز سعد
الدكتور فواز مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض يعني دعم حكومي
تمكين للمشاريع الصغيره الناشئه يقابله
ايضا حتى رسوم ماليه او غرامات احيانا
عاليه كما يقول طبعا بعض المستثمرين او
اصحاب الاعمال
بين هذا الدعم تلك الرسوم المطلوب من صاحب
المشروع برايك
مساء النور
تقرير جدا ممتاز ولكن القى باللون كثيره
على همم الرسوم
همم الحكوميه هذا جزء من الاسباب يعني
واحد من اسباب الرئيسي صحيح
يعني حسب الدراسات
يعني عندنا سيبي انسايد
يقول انه 93% من المشاريع الناشئه تفشل في
عامها الثالث
[موسيقى]
لاسباب كثيره جدا من ضمن
ضعف الخبره عند رائد الاعمال من ضمنها
يعني عدم وجود فريق عمل جيد همم احنا لا
نولد يا دكتور يعني يعني اي صاحب عمل ناشئ
او شركه صغيره هناك حتميه لفشل هذا
المشروع الناشئ او الصغير في عام الثالث
او الثاني نعم اذا لم يكن هناك رصيد
تراكمي من الخبرات المتنوعه لدى هذا الشخص
سواء كان بدراسه او بعده مشاريع جربها
واشتغل عليها هو اعمال ثقلت تجربته وخبرته
بلا شك هذا مو بس عندنا في كل العالم ممكن
تكون مثلا قله الخبره هي السبب ال همم
الوحيد اللي فشل هذا المشروع او انها او
اغلاق او تعليقه او حتى يعني خلينا نقول
تاجيله
نبدا بسبب الرئيسي الكبير هو في خلل في
اللي احنا بنسميه البزنس مودل كم بس او
نموذج العمل التجاري هذا نموذج العمل
يشتمل على ايش اول شيء القيمه المضافه من
المشروع قد لا تكون واضحه لدى رائد
الاعمال ومؤسسه المشروع قد لا يكون منتجك
او خدمتك لها حاجه في السوق
ضعفت تخطيط التوقعات الماليه هيكل
الايرادات هيكل التكاليف التسعير نفذ
الكاش ال- ال- فريق العمل توقيت نزول
الخدمه والمشروع همم حماس ضعف الحماس همم
الدكتور في في موضوع ايضا مهم اخر دائما
اي شخص صاحب مشروع ناشئه ويبدا في هذا
العمل بيكون امام همم يعني شيء مفترض انه
يعمل اللي هو دراسه الجدول لهذا المشروع
برايك احيانا هل هذا خلل رئيسي ربما انه
دراسه جدوى هذه لم تكون دقيقه لم تكون
صحيحه وبالتالي تنعكس اكثر على صاحب العمل
تجبره على الاغلاق او على
رفع يده من هذا العمل يعني بالضبط هذا هذا
نشوفه كثير جدا سواء في المشاريع عن
الناشئه التقليديه زي المطاعم والكافيهات
وغيرها او في المشاريع المبنيه على
الابتكار والتقنيه التطبيقات وما هي ذلك
دائما
معرفه ارقام المشروع وكم يدخل وكم التسعير
وكما الربح وكم الخساره ووضوح هاني دراسه
جدوى امر مهم جدا هو سبب رئيسي طيب
دكتور اذا مشروع او فشل كما قلت اشرح يصير
على الدعم الحكومي لهذا المشروع سواء من
بنك التنميه او من المنشات او غير يعني
طبعا بلا شك احنا نقول انه فيه انت الان
المنافسه زادت والاميله يعني يبغى خدمه
مميزه وممتازه
وروؤيتنا في 20 30 البلد قاعده تعزز
باتجاه الاحترافيه في الاعمال
الناس الصغار اللي ما يقدروا يقدموا خدمات
راقيه قد لا يكون لهم وجود في المستقبل
وبالتالي لذلك الناس تشتكي من كثره الرسوم
لكن في نفس الوقت عندك اكثر من 10 15
برنامج الحكومي يسهل لرائد عند الاعمال ان
يشق الطريق يعني بنك التنميه الاجتماعيه
هذا واحد ولديه اكثر من 10 برامج تبدا من
تمويل من 300,000 الى 8,000,000 عندك بعد
كده همم هي العمل للمشاهده الصغيره
المتوسطه
اذا صار اكبر في الشركات مثل الاستثمار
الجري وغيره خليني اسالك اخيرا عن عن عن
مواقع السوق السعودي اليوم في ما يخص هذه
همم خلينا نسميها المشاريع الصغيره او
الناشئه برايك انت دكتور فواز سعد هل وصل
السوق السعودي الى الاكتفاء من هذه
المشاريع من هذه المنشات ايضا الصغيره
وبالتالي نسبه نجاح اي مشروع يعني ستكون
ضئيله مقارنه بمكان عليه الوضع قبل سنتين
الى ثلاث
مزدهر ومتنوع يبنى على المشاريع الصغيره
والناشئه لذلك السوق موجود طالما رايد
الاعمال عرف هو بالضبط ايش يقدم وكيف
يتميز عن المنافسين ويقدم خدمه جديده
ويخلق حاجه او يضيف قيمه مميزه مختلفه عن
المنافسين في السوق وهو يستطيع الوصول
بمشروعه ومنتجه الى بره الامان والنجاح
ذلك
من المشاريع الصغيره
من مكه المكرمه الينا الاكاديميه المهتمه
الاعمال الدكتور سعد شكرا